if you want to hear how core lines early
childhood experiences helped her survive
and save her parents later on then stick
around to the end of this video the
other mother was an evil entity who
preyed on the souls of children living
in a particular house for hundreds of
years and after a long reign of
manipulation and terror there was only
one girl who was able to outwit her and
finally put an end to the horrors that
took place there welcome to horror
history in today's lesson I'm analyzing
the life of Coraline Jones the brave
Explorer who was the first to ever
survive the wonders of an alternate
realm called to the Otherworld in order
to understand where Coraline got the
strength needed to take down the other
mother we first need to take things back
to the beginning Coraline Jones was born
as the only daughter of two loving
parents named Mel and Charlie in the
movie but who are not named in the book
although they do care for Coraline
they're oftentimes very busy with their
work both of them work from home on
computers and I've never related to two
characters so hard before
[Music]
Portland's favorite pastime was to go
out exploring but the house that the
Joneses lived in was in a bad part of
town where people would throw away their
unwanted junk so her parents forbid her
from exploring in that area Coraline is
persistent about it though and one day
her dad agrees to go with her and they
come across a stream at the bottom of
the hill
mr. Jones tells her to run back up the
hill as fast as she could and she obeys
as he stays behind when she got back to
the top of the hill he runs up after and
picks her up he would later explain that
the air was filled with wasps and he
stayed back to take the stings in order
to give her time to escape he would
explain to her that he didn't see the
action as a bravery it wasn't brave
because he wasn't scared it was the only
thing he could do but going back to get
his glasses when he knew the wasps were
there that's when he was really scared
that was a brave this scene not only
shows how much her father actually cares
for her but it would give her the
bravery she needed later in the story
she also learned the value of resilience
as a child when her mother first took
the training wheels off her bicycle and
she ended up getting scrapes on top of
scrapes but had a sense of achievement
when she finally mastered it Coraline
had an otherwise normal childhood she
came to find that she had an intense
discomfort around spiders and she
enjoyed eating simple foods but wasn't a
fan of her father's complicated recipes
like his leek and potato stew with
tarragon garnish and melted Gruyere
cheese
she was also not a fan of coconut when
Cora lines grandmother passed away she
left all of her expensive furniture to
the family which Coraline found very
uncomfortable but it didn't matter
because she wasn't allowed to play in
the drawing room where it was kept
anyway the main story takes place one
summer three weeks before the beginning
of school we know that this wasn't her
first year of school because it mentions
that she's been there multiple times
before so I guess that she's going into
second or third grade the family moved
into a new house just outside of London
which was in a much safer area for
Coraline to explore and play in the
Joneses owned only part of the house
they were above miss [ __ ]
and miss forceable who were on the
ground floor and below mr. Bobo who was
on the top floor there was also a unit
adjacent to them on the second floor
which was vacant at the time that they
moved in one of the first discoveries
that Coraline makes upon moving in is
the door to the vacant flat which filled
her with intrigue the door was locked
and on one rainy day mrs. Jones shows
her that there's only a brick wall
behind it which was likely put up when
the house was divided up the next day as
she's heading out to go explore mr. Bobo
from upstairs tells her that the mice
he's supposedly training for his jumping
mouse circus had a message for her
telling her don't go through the door
this seems to suggest that the animals
are privy to the other world in a way
that people are not which we see later
with the cats
or align sets out to find a well that
miss [ __ ] and miss forceable told her
about which is supposedly very deep and
very dangerous and coralline kind of
finds this exciting because she finds
everything else boring school is only a
week away now and it's raining outside
so Coraline stays in and draws an
abstract picture which looks like this
the eye is lost in the mist a
forewarning about how she would soon be
lost in the other world another warning
comes when she visits the old ladies
downstairs and they read her tea leaves
to predict that she'll be in danger
there's no siblings or friends to play
with she thinks a little danger would be
some welcome excitement miss [ __ ]
suggests Coraline has no idea what that
means and I didn't either at first so
let's break it to him miss Spinks main
thing is that she's a retired theatre
actress so she's referencing an old
theater superstition that performers
shouldn't wear green because it's bad
luck and it was thought that they would
not stand out from the background which
consisted of a green trees grass and
bushes
Coraline however while shopping for
school clothes later in the story wanted
to buy a green pair of gloves to make
her stand out from her classmates and it
would ultimately be her alternate way of
thinking that got her out of a few scary
situations miss [ __ ] and miss forceable
also give her a stone with a hole in it
which they believe might help her in
some way one afternoon when she's once
again terribly bored with her life her
mom goes out to get food for lunch and
Coraline opens the door to the drawing
room but instead of a wall of bricks
there's a hallway it leads to an almost
identical version of her world but
certain things look more sinister like
the picture of the boy in the drawing
room who is normally just staring at
some bubbles but now looks like he's
planning to do something very nasty to
them Coraline meets the other mother who
is like Coraline 'he's real mother but
has buttons for eyes and has much more
interest in paying attention to Coraline
they have a lunch with food that
Coraline actually really likes we've
been waiting for you for a long time
said Cora lines other father yep
typically not a great idea to talk to
people who say that they tell her that
everyone has a set of other parents she
just never knew about hers until now the
rats upstairs sing and perform for her
which she finds a little off-putting but
is willing to look past it because at
least it's something interesting she
goes out to explore and finds the cat in
the garden can talk now he tells her
he's the same cat from her world and
hints at the possibility of danger in
this one
[Music]
[Applause]
the next wonder of the other worlds that
Coraline visits is the location that
usually contains miss [ __ ] and miss
forcible splat which is now a small
theater the audience is filled with
talking dogs and the old ladies perform
on unicycles onstage before stepping out
of the old lady suits and revealing that
they're actually thin young women with
black button eyes perhaps to resemble
the ideal versions of [ __ ] enforcible
told about in their stories Coraline
volunteers to take part in the stunt in
which this other miss forcible throws a
knife just above her head to pop a
balloon and she gets a box of chocolates
as a reward after finding out that the
theater will continue performing forever
she decides to leave and thinks it's
time to be getting back to her own world
before she goes she runs into her other
parents who are just waiting for her
there they tell her that if she likes it
he or she can stay forever she just has
to sew these buttons over her eyes she
basically knope's right out of there and
passes back through the door when she
gets to the other side the hallway
behind her is replaced by the brick wall
before she can turn back around her mom
still hasn't returned when she gets back
so she watches TV as her parents are
gone all day she asked the ladies
downstairs about them but they haven't
seen anything and they're about to take
off to visit miss Pink's knees she goes
to the supermarket to get her own meal
which consisted of limeade cake and
apples
she wrote a story on her dad's computer
but at 3:12 a.m. her parents were still
not back and she cried herself to sleep
in their bed I think this is an
important sequence because Cora lines
parents are gone and she has free reign
to do whatever she wants all the time
but it isn't as fulfilling as she
thought it would be just as the other
world appears to be this amazing place
where everything is catered towards
pleasing her and she finds that it has
its drawbacks the real world is also
less fun without limitations I think
we've all experienced this in some form
when you're old enough to buy your own
groceries you don't just buy your
favourite food every day because then
it's not special when you do have it the
next day she's woken up by the cats
being back in the real world it doesn't
speak but it leads her to the mirror
downstairs and in the reflection she
sees her parents looking sad and alone
her mom leaves a message with her finger
which says help us backwards Coraline
knows what she has to do she gathers her
bravery marches up and calls the police
one of the funniest parts of the book in
my opinion of course they don't take her
seriously at all so then she brings a
couple of the apples and the stone with
a hole in it
and heads back to the other world with
the cats what we do here just go back
back back back the other mother is
waiting for her there and tries to tell
her that her parents give her the slip
because they weren't interested in
having her anymore
she has one of her rats steal the key to
the Gateway door thus trapping Coraline
inside her other parents go to bed and
the cat suggests that the other mother
loves games and maybe if Coraline
challenges her she can win her parents
freedom back Coraline is terrified to
sleep in the other world so she
barricades her room using the toy box
before she goes to sleep when she goes
downstairs the next day things are
getting even more weird than they were
before she goes to her other father's
study and finds him just standing there
kind of pretending to work but not
actually getting anything done she
realizes that the house is mostly the
same as her house but there are a few
small differences like the snow globe on
the drawing room mantel which is usually
empty she also realizes that this other
reality is really just the house and the
property that immediately surrounds it
he figures out that the place was
created by the other mother to catch her
like a spider in a web and that she
hasn't bothered to create anything
beyond what you could see from the house
then she notices that the trees further
back in the distance look worse and
worse and it gets more and more misty
and she eventually walks all the way
around and back to the house as if for
one large sphere this entire description
reminds me of one thing a video game the
other mother created this world to
entice Coraline and get her to want to
stay forever just as a video game
developer creates a fun world for the
player
if you break outside the boundaries of
where you're supposed to be the
developers put less effort the trees
look very pixelated because you're not
supposed to see this part up close
you're supposed to stay immersed in the
game that's what video game devs want
and that's what the other mother wants
as well I think there's a video game
metaphor in Coraline it's very similar
to the favorite food analogy I mentioned
earlier playing a video game can be fun
but you don't want to just spend all
your time there and lose touch with the
real world when Coraline gets back the
other mother locks are behind the mirror
for having poor manners and it is there
where she meets the ghosts of the other
kids whose souls were stolen by the
other mother one of whom refers to her
as the beldum they tell her that the
beldam will take her life joy heart and
soul and leave her hollow and yes I'm
aware that my logo resembles the hollow
mask from bleach you can stop commenting
that every day every day the next day
the other mother brings her back through
the mirror into the kitchen and Coraline
challenges her to a bat if she can find
the souls of the ghost children and her
parents then the other mother must let
her go other mother accepts swearing her
right hand
but Coraline has no idea how she's
actually gonna find these things until
she sees her reflection in the mirror
where the Adderstone given to her by the
old women downstairs is a glowing green
coal this gives her the idea to look
through it okay and that is one little
Coraline decided you know what I'm out
no but she did find an ember colored
marble that emitted the voice of the
ghost boy and collected it which by the
way is another video game comparison I
can't tell you how many video games
force you to collect three spiritual
stones or 101 Power Cells or whatever
these things are so she gets the marble
and with each one she gets the world
around her kind of starts falling apart
so next place she looks is in the
theater where the book describes some of
the most horrific creatures ever created
[Music]
Coraline goes in search of the next soul
in the theatre which is now abandoned
and dusty she casts a torch light up on
the ceiling and sees these dog bad
things they aren't too scary in the film
but in the book they're described as
hairless jelly ish creatures that may
have once been dogs but had wings and
hung like bats and spiders there's some
kind of egg sac thing behind the stage
which contains two heads two of each
limb and when viewed through the stone
Coraline could see one of the souls
glowing inside so Cora lion actually had
to reach inside of this thing build n
bro style and retrieve it but she
accidentally wakes it up when she sees
the face I can't even describe it any
better than it is in the book so let me
just read that excellent it resembles
the younger versions of miss [ __ ] and
miss forcible but twisted and squeezed
together like two lumps of wax that had
been melted and melded together into one
and ghastly objects yep that's pretty
messed up one of the hands grabs out at
her and starts yelling at her calling
her a thief as much as I love the movie
I'd kind of like to see the David
Cronenberg version of this mostly just
so I can see his interpretation of this
scene when she gets back out the world
is starting to contort and lose its form
she tells the other mother that she's
found two of the three souls and other
mother tosses her a key to the other
second floor flat remember this is the
equivalent of the vacant flat from core
lines world
it's her curiosity about that area that
got her into this whole mess and it
would get her into more trouble again
here this is the most haunting location
that Coraline ever has to explore she
finds a giant dead
spider in the bath one of her worst
fears and eventually makes it to a
trapdoor leading into a cellar when she
gets down there she turns on the lights
and finds crude paintings on the wall
the bulb was not bright enough to fully
make them out it was a bad smell from a
rubbish pile in the corner cardboard box
is covered in mildew and decaying
curtains under what she noticed a pair
of thieves she comes to find that the
feet belonged to a pale puffy deformed
blob that sits up and stares at her with
a dark button eyes I would conclude that
like everything she had encountered in
the other world the other father she had
seen was only an illusion
the beldam had manipulated this thing to
look and act like her father in order to
trick her and she had discarded it here
when she was done with it I think maybe
the creepiest part of this is how when
it speaks a mouth opens in the mouth
less face and strands of pale stuff
sticks to the web's this is also an
important moment for Korra lines
character development because she tells
herself you can be brave which is a
reference to the story about her real
dad getting stung by the wasp stir her
now she's got to find that same bravery
to maneuver her way out of this
situation and be the one to save him she
gets out of it by pulling the thing's
button off when it attacks her running
for the trapdoor and locking the
abandoned flat when she escapes her last
place to look is the top flat where mr.
Bobo normally lives in this world there
was no man up there just a horde of rats
that give form to the man's clothes she
spots the last soul glowing in her
viewfinder but it's being taken away by
one of the rats
Coraline gives chase but ended up
falling on the stairs and the rat
appeared to get away but luckily for her
she had befriended the cats and he'd
captured it earning her the final soul
upon finding it the house flattened even
more until it looked like a charcoal
scribble on a grey paper and she quickly
went into the house to find her parents
and confront the other mother the ghost
children speak to her through the
marbles telling her that the beldam
won't hold true to her word
even if Coraline wins so she comes up
with a cunning plan to outsmart her
after spending pretty much the entire
adventure thinking about it Coraline
realizes where her parents are hidden in
the snow globe on the mantle the one
major difference between the two worlds
she tells the other mother she thinks
that they're in the passageway between
the worlds that's getting her to open it
and prove her wrong Coraline grabs the
snow globe while her back is turned and
throws the cat and is able to escape
back to her world bringing her mom and
dad with her and freeing the souls of
the children when she gets back home she
appreciates her world for what it is and
we know that she's completed her
character transformation when she falls
asleep on the uncomfortable armchair in
the drawing room her father makes
pineapple pizza for dinner which is kind
of a compromise for her she eats the
pizza but leaves the pineapple
pineapple chunks are the only good part
[Music]
that night she dreamt of a picnic under
an old oak tree where she played with
the children whose souls had been
rescued it was a sweet moment because
she finally has friends to play with in
a way but then she sees a shadow across
their faces and they tell her that
there's more that she has to do the
other mother had sworn by her right hand
to let her go if she won the game so now
the hand was scuttling around the world
like a spider trying to steal back the
key
the next day Coraline visits miss [ __ ]
and miss forceable again and they tell
her almost everything as well but they
do see an ominous hand in her future
Coraline comes up with one final plan to
try to do away with the other mother
once and for all she sneaks back to the
spot that she had initially set out
exploring for when they first moved into
the house the old well making sure that
she's not followed she removed the
planks from the top and sets up a mock
tea party using the tea cups to weigh
down the picnic blanket and hide the
fact that the well was open then she
goes back to the house dangling the key
around her hand for all the see and
loudly says where she'll be playing and
this prompts the hand to go after her
and try to steal back the key she places
it in the center of the picnic blanket
and the hand goes crashing down into the
depths of the well when it weighs down
the blanket she replaces the planks
forever trapping the hand at the bottom
of the well that night as the summer
ends she hears what she thinks is the
mouse circus getting ready for a
performance upstairs
Coraline story is like many tales about
kids her age a coming-of-age story but
her transformation deals with much more
nuanced themes she goes through the
stage that every kid goes through
whether interests are maturing and they
have to learn to balance these interests
something that you're very used to doing
as an adults but can even then be
sometimes challenging I think the
biggest takeaway is that you have to
learn to appreciate the dull parts of
life because they make the exciting
portions that much better by comparison
she also has to learn to grow up and
face her fear in a mature way taking
examples from her parents and ultimately
using those experiences to save her real
mom and dad when they need her most so
that's the history of Coraline Jones but
there's so much more lore to unpack with
her greatest enemy the other mother or
the beldam so make sure you join me for
my next tour history to learn all about
that your homework this lesson is to
subscribe the Seas world for new Horrors
every week wring that death battle for
notifications and outs
in the next one assuming we both survive
[Music]